today we're gonna have uh two
back-to-back talks
about um
that you know
extend basic lattice problems go beyond
them and do even cooler things that we
know how to do with basic class problems
and i guess it's up to us to figure out
if these uh
extended problems are secure we can do
it from
basic bias problems so
thank everyone for coming so i'm going
to be talking about optimal broadcast
encryption and 7x policy from
invasive like assumptions so to begin
with my slides from uh
from simon's 2015.
so the same old motivating uh scenario
suppose we want to do a sedating and
aerobic data which is like a motivator
thank you but very old it doesn't work
anymore
right so yeah you though who wants to
you know join some website and it's
interesting online dating so the first
thing the user does is to create a
profile which contains sensitive
information about them you know um i
don't know where they went to school
where they live et cetera et cetera and
they'd like to limit access to this
profile ideally to people who satisfy
their dating criteria
so for instance uh you know something
like this or to keep up with the times a
phd in crypto
so uh right so you're just showing the
website and when they do uh right they
have different attributes
oh my light gray didn't show that sounds
like gray
yeah it shows up over there okay it's
not that important i don't think um
right they have attributes that say
something about themselves and when they
join the website uh they get a secret
key that's specifically tailored to
their attributes
and the basic correctness requirement is
that uh you know you have a key that
satisfy the attribute and the before
attribute of satisfy dating criterion
should be able to decrypt the profile
and otherwise for everyone else who
doesn't they should learn nothing
whatsoever about the profile even if
they collude so they shouldn't be able
to mix their message their keys in such
a way that allows them to cheat so this
is basically the notion of uh
accurate-based encryption concretely
this is actually the ciphertext policy
version because the policy f is on the
ciphertext so more generally in a cpa be
we have a sender who holds a function f
and a message m and wants to encrypt a
message and secret key is also still a
bit strings and the basic correctness
requirement says that uh youtube will
decrypt and then m if only f of x equals
zero okay so here zero is true and not
equal to zero is false
um and right and now this should hold
even their collusions
okay so uh so about a decade ago now uh
we showed that you can actually get abe
for circuit so very expressive uh
policies for expressive functions f from
the standard lw assumption
so in the context of this talk uh i'm
going to call e b s b plus e so x is on
the left i'm going to use squiggly
underline to denote plus norms so this
is lw assumption and this scheme is
actually
what we call a key policy scheme
but it does immediately but using
universal circuit it gives you actually
a ciphertext policy ab as well so it
does solve this problem except that your
cypher stack sizes are very large your
ciphertext size is going to be roughly
the circuit size of f
so uh recently there's been a flurry of
works trying to address this limitation
and trying to get the cpa vt with small
step attacks
uh in particular they get cipher text as
a polynomial the depth of the circuit
times the length of the input x
so think of the depth of the circuit as
roughly logarithmic in circuit size so
this is really a polylogaritamine
circuit
more generally sub linear circuit size
okay and now these constructions don't
quite get out of you anymore they get
lwe plus a little bit more uh and
depending on which set of results the
first set of results oh sorry in
particular these results are interesting
uh well they're equally interesting but
they also yield a solution to what's
called
optimal broadcast encryption schemes so
in broadcast encryption we have a set uh
the f is instead of end users and uh the
function essentially corresponds to a
set membership okay and here if it was
cpav of this kind these kind of
parameters you get broadcast encryption
schemes where your parameter size is
polygonal in the total number of users
capital m
let's say making circular security
assumptions or other strong assumptions
this is effective inherent limitation
can you get around
[Music]
yeah i don't know how to get abe by
making securities for those options
so uh
but let me try to say a bit more
so uh so one reason for doing this is
and let me now quickly say what kind of
assumptions do these schemes use
so the first set of this results you uh
basically get cp abe for a lot depth
circuits and c1 and they use our lwe
plus pairings
essentially they use a generic model but
you can that part can be uh
relaxed to some kind of knowledge
assumption but basically out of the
replacements okay so you need a little
bit more lwe
so right the second of these results
gives a construction uh from lattice
heuristics in a sense that it only uses
lattice algebra but the paper does not
give a reduction to a simpler function
so so in this case yeah we don't even
know how to for instance reduce security
of the scheme to some kind circular
security assumption
sort of the state of the art for uh
cpa-b for circuits with a small
ciphertext size uh in this work we give
a new cpab for circuits with small
circuit text size in fact our civil
texas is slightly smaller but that's not
the main uh
thing here but we look at it from
neutral assumptions
so uh compared to the first of this
works we got rid of pairings and we get
to uh i guess the arbitrary depth
circuits and
the second of this works we actually get
to uh somewhat simpler than this
assumption
uh yeah we don't even know that
yeah we don't have it here you'll see in
a second
uh
right
okay good
uh and right as a corollary uh we also
get optimal broadcast encryption from
these new languages
right okay as a warm-up let me give you
a quick warm-up to our construction uh
the warm-up part is the same as
fireworks so uh the starting point is
this uh what we call this key equation
that underlies uh all prior
ad circuits but this is the equation
that we were trying to talk about uh
eight years ago now i guess so basically
this equation says that so uh on the
left hand side you should think of a
minus x density as a shorthand of a i
minus x i g you've seen these
expressions before so this expression
just says that roughly speaking starting
from a very white matrix a you can
derive some which is a sub f that
depends on your circuit f and then this
expression you can record a minus x
tends to g to a f minus f of x
so the starting point of construction is
the following uh our master public key
is going to be a so the width of a is
going to grow with the length of x
and the cam we're going to put a sub f
into the cam i'm going to put a a minus
x sensor g into some combination of the
same thing as secret key
particularly the cam is lw sample with
respect to
a sub f so this really squiggly
underlines for plus noise as it's a
random uh encryption randomness
and we're going to make sure that when
we design the ciphertext and the super
key in such a way that the product is
the lw sample with respect to a massive
sensor g how quickly the way we do this
is uh we're going to publish an
additional matrix b in the master public
key the cipher text is going to be lw
sample respect to b so think of b as
having you know standard n times unlock
q
and your secret key is going to be a
random gaussian pre majors with respect
to b
of the target a minus x substitute okay
so basically if you multiply these two
of them together you'll get uh s times
the
accessor g
all right so notice that the ciphertext
size because b essentially has fixed
width so the ciphertext size is
independent of the uh
of the length of x
and the dimensions of this are going to
the brown circle
just because uh inherited from the key
equation
why are you doing this again you didn't
do this
right so this is our basic scheme
and in fact you can show that you can
get correctness for this scheme if you
multiply the two of them you get s times
a minus sign so g you use this formula
for evaluation you can recover the can
and in fact you can show that this game
is secure if the average only gets one
second key
is much wider but
so right this is sort of the starting
point of the prior constructions
at least for bk20 the starting point of
this two construction is actually
absolutely more complicated but
this basically the basic construction
so your point is that uh before before
you did this b and b inverse
right
index dependent on both f and x
what's the secret key
uh this is just
what
thing b times this gaussian is
exponential when you say b inverse what
do you mean first it's a random function
such that b times
and i call this expression
so it's a randomized
so to complete this expression you'll
need the treble b
and then yeah you're using the secret
entropy is the random which is
so this is our basic scheme making sure
that it's secure when you watch the key
and in fact it's easy to see that this
game is insecure if you get two secret
keys
roughly speaking if you multiply the
ciphertext by the secret key the same
out of the ecp s appears twice you can
essentially recover s
so the approach from prior works to try
to get a scheme that secure against
multiple secret keys against collusions
is to try to in some sense randomize
your s so that when you try to do this
partial decryption you get a different
size for every new secret key uh ski
uh concretely in the uh
uh in the bb candidate so brachasky and
vacuum
size of the form are ri times the square
matrix s
where your square matrix s is going to
be your new encryption randomness and
your ri is essentially going to be
gaussian and it's going to be a gaussian
that comes from the secret key
so this ensures
that this si changes every time we try
to do the encryption and at least will
prevent the attack
so let's so this is the scale uh this
this is going to be the approach we're
going to take
so what we want to do is to design a
scheme such that the product of the
ciphertext is of the following form r
times s times a minus x tends to g
so without the r that's the one key
secure scheme that we started out with
but this is the one we want to get so
that the uh seeing something changes
every time we do a new decrease
uh right so the main difficulty of
achieving this decryption in variant is
that you have a quantity that depends on
the ciphertext stuck in between the
quantities that depend on the secret key
so you cannot decompose it into
something that is dependent on
ciphertext multiplied by something like
the number of secret key
so a bbk is a very clever way to uh
realize these invariants so they use
some techniques from identity based
encryption but that's not what we're
going to do
instead we're going to rely on uh
you know a very fairly simple uh matrix
identity this matrix identity in the
literature is what's called our
vectorization so basically what this
says is that instead of working with uh
the matrix s you
what was called the flattened version of
s which is the row vector you get from
concatenating the rows of s what this
allows you to do is it allows you to
move s from the middle to the left hand
side
so now s appears on the left hand side
but in this form and then your r moves
to the other side with extra tension
just writing it down
sequence
and then
rewriting it
no no no no i'm saying this is just uh
sort of writing the thing on top as a
sequence of multilinear polynomials
yeah
yeah it's cheating you may
make multiplication commutative somehow
yeah
okay so this is uh this is all very
little i mean this particular variant is
easy because uh this thing is
essentially
the more general version
right so the nice thing about this is
that now s approved the left hand side
and r and x appears on the right hand
side
so now we can apply the same paradigm
from before we can decompose this into
the product of the ciphertext and a
secret key
so now your in your new cipher text the
uh
the uh right that's going to be b and
your out of each secret itself being s
is going to be the flattened version of
s
which is a row vector
and your secret key will have an extra
tensor thumbs up
so let's give us the following cpap
scheme
uh
very simple cpap scheme and uh to the
best of my knowledge there's no attack
on this key
so the main difference from this
previous from the previous scheme is
that now you have this astral
randomization r that comes from a tensor
product for correctness you actually
need to publish r under clear
so the only um the only uh so the only
hidden entropy here again is as before
is actually the
randomness useful gaussian prematures
like the major difference from reports
now you're taking b inverse of something
that's real and not uniform it doesn't
work
right good uh in the previous scheme if
you look at one secret key the marginal
distribution if you ignore the muscle
publication
yeah yeah you're right i don't know how
to prove monkey security that's a good
opportunity
r is not necessarily public right you
don't have to make it uh uh our needs
will be shot for correctness sure but
it's not public uh so for for our scheme
we'll use options and you'll see what
wait no is our public or is that not
public so our needs should be short for
correctness but public is it r is public
you need r to be public for also for
creditors so basically what happened is
that when you evolve this whole thing
you get r comes s times
about something like pretty fundamental
so like
you said like okay this is problematic
this ciphertext times secret key equals
r times s times other stuff because the
secret key is on two sides
uh the secret key
that's why i'm making correctness but
ours
public so it's not oh it's public yes uh
yes okay the uh that uh i'll show you in
a second
okay so so the intuition
uh no
uh roughly speaking uh sorry let's go
back here uh the intuition here is that
uh you know you can treat r as the
algorithm matrix public matrix then r
from the sugar random so it's okay when
r is probably
oh that's roughly the equation yeah i'll
come back a second proportion so even if
you don't make r probably can't you
recover or like if you multiply b so you
need r
okay but even if you don't explicitly
make it you can still recover r from
reading also yeah because basically when
you do decryption uh when you do
homomorphic evolution on this you get r
times x
whereas your cam
doesn't determine r so you need to
multiply
basically you do these two together you
get r times s of f and then you multiply
this by this you get r times eight
it's uh
and r is shared
r needs to be load on and then for our
scheme what wouldn't we take out the
same for everybody i know sorry good
question uh it's a fresh alpha key yeah
so that's where your randomization comes
from okay that's a good question
let's make sure that when you multiply
different keys together you get r comes
s and the r changes so you don't end up
just with s
let's tell you about
and the intuition about why this must be
useful is the same as saying rb in bb rn
is in public also basically the
intuition is that you treat acids your
elderly secrets and there are items as
you should even in particular that's
wrong intuition
in this basic scheme correctness should
be somewhat clear
and the real question is true
okay
do you have a question
manual quick slice
we started to use r because you're
saying it's insecure to use the same as
to use the same vector as
when decrypting multiple secrets right
because you can have the same x with x i
equals to zero and x i equals to one
so now we move to using r
but then what if i have multiple secret
keys
and they all have their independent r
allow me to recover the big matrix as
multiply with the rest
[Music]
yeah then lwe should kick in where r is
the public matrix
right low norm public matrix s is the
high normal secret matrix and that's
actually okay you can switch
back and forth
yeah the f5 doesn't actually recover as
you cover s times three plus noise and
because of the g you can get rid of the
ones
but maybe it'd be easier to take this
outside
isn't the same noise reused
doesn't it come up in like cp
times just ski for different ways
i'm sorry yes it doesn't the same like
error come come up and see if you can
see it
i'm going to correlate
yeah yeah
yeah uh yeah
yes but as far as i know there is one
so since there's no attack the
question's not going to prove about this
okay
okay so let's try to prove something
about this so as a warm-up uh let's try
to prove that the product of the cyber
tax and the secret key is pseudo-random
in fact the product of many ciphertext
has many secret keys are jointly to the
right okay if we can prove this this
essentially rules out the previous
attack because the previous attack
really only uses the fact that you can
multiply the subjects by the secret key
that's the first
thing okay we should go our boy started
showing that this expression is still
random
again we have a different uh ri for
every secret key
um all right so what's the first thing
we'll do our intuition behind why
randomization works is from lwe so
instead of the outer assumption that
says that our items as plus noise
is pseudorandom even if you are given
our eyes
and pseudo-randomness will continue to
hold if you multiply the left hand side
and the right hand side by low numbers
quickly
yeah this is
joint distribution
even given arrives
and this will hold even if you multiply
uh things of
both sides by low number by zonal matrix
uh you need that to be low
non-perception
okay if a has no no and you represent g
by i then yes
then this is your random and then now on
the right hand side you get different
axes you can now do a hybrid argument
over the outer e sequence and get the
right hand solution
and i only know how to prove this
statement if a has line it could be true
all right so this is good uh this almost
achieves what we want except now we have
to work with a which is slow now
and turns out the this key equation that
we have from before works even if a has
low norm and when you have identified
instead of the gaussian matrix
the only problem now is that your noise
growth instead of being singularly
exponential and circuit that is going to
be w
exponential because you don't get the
you don't get the savings from the
repetitions
something works in fact here this
equation is even easier you don't have
to do the g inverse you just whenever
you multiply you just multiply whenever
the you know because of no g inverse the
noise becomes a yeah
it's like the early version of gfw
yeah so you get exponential circuit
there every time you multiply uh the uh
with every multiplication get your your
norm double your norm squares
so your exponential so if you nicely
plug into the previous construction you
will get separate secret uh secret key
sign that's exponential
instead of our polynomial
so uh right so for general circuit this
is not terribly interesting because
roughly speaking we already know how to
get lcp abe where the uh
uh supply and secure key signs
but it's sufficient for broadcast
encryption because broadcast encryption
corresponds to circuits with extremely
low depth in fact the depth is a doubly
logarithmic sinusoid
so this is uh so even with our low
normal a and identity matrix it's
sufficient to get our optimal
concentration
so for the rest of this talk for now
we're going to work i and just focus on
getting optimal broken segregation
so it's circuits with large family
naturally uh yeah yeah yeah if you think
about aromatic circuits you think
you yeah yeah the the fan in is going to
be end and the construction can handle
large panels i guess it can yeah the
only interesting circuit i know of
extremely small depth is broadcast
encryption
i'm saying
can handle gates with large fan m yeah
you can handle it yeah yeah probably
speaking of that is much better than
that your size you know your addition
for three is actually
and you multiply by the size right yeah
but that's fine
yeah your final is going to be n so the
growth is going to be n but your uh your
noise group is logarithmic
so this is going to be okay
so this is w dot i mean uh this is
doubling over domain and this is uh n
and this expression basically you get
you get an end here and an end and you
get okay oh no no sorry you can enter
the lock ending
how is this different than the original
id like then
rather than
because my noise growth is uh as doubly
exponential and definition of
explanation why what this looks like
with the identity matrix
because i don't get to do the g inverse
anymore i see
so every time i do a multiplication
instead of uh multiplied by security
parameter i get i square the x square
device
yeah so instead of uh
instead of uh
a1 times times rg inverse of a2 i just
do a 1 times a 2.
so here the norm would be uh this is
always small so this 5 by here both
questions
okay so far so good
so uh what we have roughly showed is
that uh so we need to modify our schemes
to look a bit like this now and what
i've shown so far is that uh you know
the product of the subtitle
there's nothing inherent here that
prevents you from using
the composition or in other words
yeah so yeah there's nothing inherent
that prevents you from using g inverse
here
right uh there's nothing inversely no uh
the this statement you want it to be low
norm right any a to be low normal
you have you have the g and then you
have identity and you have everything in
between
you know what i mean like uh
there are gadget matrices that allow you
to think of both small numbers so small
you know it grows from uh
you know so so
i'm not sure maybe we should take it out
for now
but certainly right now i do use the
fact that a has low norm to prove this
statement
yeah it's one starting smallmouth doing
but i do use it right now maybe that
weighs around it but this is where it
would just
any questions
okay good good so so far i have shown
that the product of the cycle is super
key to random well it's what i really
want is to show that the ciphertext is
still the random given the secret keys
so there's a gap between the two of them
and now our basic intuition is that we
really want to deduce the fact that the
ciphertext pseudorandom given the secret
keys from the fact that the productions
have pretend security should work
and our basic intuition in general is
that if i give you uh the ciphertext of
this form the secret key for this form
and our basic intuition is that if you
are given an out of each sample and some
gaussian pre-images the only thing that
the evidence really learns is the
product of the two quantities
so basically all known attacks roughly
speaking has
falls into this category
and if this is true this basically says
that uh you know the only thing you can
do to cycle that's given the secret key
is to multiply the two of them again
i've already shown that uh if you
multiply two of them you should random
then you know the decomposed version
should
okay and to formalize this intuition
we're going to put uh we formalize this
intuition via a new uh lattice
assumption
especially what we call evasive lwe and
it's also uh proposed independently by
row term and should talk about it yeah
so uh but the version here is simple
uh for broadcast encryption okay so
we're roughly speaking
uh this is what ross is thinking the
evasive algebra assumption looks like
since they're given some distribution p
p corresponds to this a minus excessive
use in our application
consumption says that if s b plus e and
s p plus e prime is show the random then
s b is to the random given b
so it captures the idea that if
if given this expression gives
restriction if you multiply them
together they are pseudo-random then if
you separate them this is to do it
okay uh
right and we needed to call given b and
p
let me give you some examples so for
instance if p is a uniform distribution
then uh you can actually show both the
precondition the post condition from the
lw assumption
so true implies through so this is true
whereas if b is the gadget matrix then
the pre-condition is false the post
condition is also false so you know
there's no contradiction
so now we have a pop quiz uh let u be
the uniform distribution okay consider
following three p's
the first is uniform competitive uniform
the second is uniform concatenated
uniform one is left right the other one
is top bottom and the third one is
uniform concatenated with the gradual
matrix top and bottom
okay so uh for this p
all right
you know uh is this statement true
for each of these three p's
okay so whatever popped up let's do a
quick pop quiz uh
it's okay to be wrong uh who thinks that
the first one is true
okay
who thinks that the second one is true
what's the question again okay good
she
you is a uniform distribution i give you
three examples for p
and for each of these examples for p
is sb pseudo-random given b
are you asking only about the pulse
condition or like both of just four
conditions
so we know that the post condition is
true p is random okay what if p is sort
of a structure right
what's the difference in the first two
matrixes
so
this this means that i give you you know
like d1 and b2 and then b can be one to
you
b and b
this one states that uh you know
in the first one basically i want b from
b1 to u
that's sort of what's happening in the
first one in the second one i basically
have b times
v 1 b 2.
all right so that's good that's good
good good okay so so turns out the first
one is false that's an especially attack
and the second and third one you can
prove about
the first one is false because basically
you get uh you basically can collect a
basis not like basis for me
and indeed if you plug in if you check
with the precondition it will be easy to
see that the precondition is false for
the first one
because when you're multiplied by p you
get the same thing of variant twice more
or less so it's not suitable
for the second one uh it's not hard to
see that you really get out of example
where the secrets add up
for the third one uh well you basically
get out of the v sample from the top
part that will mask
the gadget
so your the first the the left half of s
is going to be elbows
so right so this thing's a highly
non-trivial statement even just to
predict whether the i think this is even
useful just as a predictor for which pvc
so as far as i know it's the best
practice you're saying these are
examples of matrices where the heuristic
is actually true
um the first one is false sorry
condition predicts it that's right
that's right that's right
uh yeah mystery are all example of the
solution that the recognition predicts
right right right
what that is
so you this is an if then statement yes
but you just showed us a bunch of if and
only f's uh uh good good so not quite
equal it is so
the first one is false yeah so the post
condition can attack the pre-conditional
response
yeah it doesn't
[Music]
like it was always either the
precondition was false and the post
condition was false or the precondition
was true when the first condition was
triggered yeah yeah
almost true i see okay assuming
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i never had a uh i never had a so
you don't want to true implies false
because
yeah yeah
yeah high school stuff yeah i don't know
about that
i said i didn't try super
yeah i didn't think about that
so the first one you can still have the
effect the second and third one you can
prove
the reduction is actually somewhere
the this one tells me slightly easier
this one requires a bit more k and in
fact we can prove a more generalized
version like u and
something with it
is
so the assumption you're not assuming
that this holds for all distributions
okay google good so this is think of
this heuristic i think they're sort of
like the generator so the application
really induces yeah
yeah
but the key is slightly complicated
[Music]
like one two three four five six seven
eight something like that right yeah
make sure
it's a question about what the word fix
means uh
it puts mass on one matrix and that's it
yeah so that's what that's what fixed
matrix means
okay so let's say p is the matrix one
two three four and then five six seven
eight and then
[Music]
that's that's the what happens to the
assumption is the question
daniel's answer is uh is that the
precondition is false
and recognition is false yeah right so
that's it
that's it
yeah
you're making the assumption on all
distributions including singleton
distributions right
you're making the assumption
just to be clear about uh non-uniformly
uh
the precondition is broken right yeah
that's right so the question doesn't
make sense for things it does make sense
but uh you know
but the assumptions okay
so let's zoom into this assumption a
little bit
and let me first say observe that
the precondition is saying something
slightly stronger
so in the post condition you can always
take sb plus e and multiply by v inverse
of p
okay and i want to say that the
precondition is a term stronger it's not
saying that this expression is to the
right
it's saying that s p plus s times p plus
fresh noise is 0
and these two things are two different
things because in fact this quantity has
low rank and this point these two
distributions are clearly distinguished
so uh the assumption doesn't just say
that the only thing that a vision can do
is multiply two quantity squared it says
that even if you're given a little bit
more noise uh that's the one push the
precondition applies
so the way to interpret the precondition
is really it roughly says that if you
multiply these two quantities together
and the higher order bits are
pseudorandom
[Music]
then the post condition is true
that's one way to justify having to add
pressure
let me just say that also the uh the the
precondition is what allows you to uh
avoid rising attaching to the future uh
on i o candidates and all these other
ones
so let me uh move on because i only have
five minutes left all right for the uh
for the application we need some
additional matrix a prime
okay so uh i'm almost done okay so this
is our scheme
so combining the evasive out of
reassumption
uh and the previous statement that we
proved from out of e you can prove that
your ciphertext
issued random given the secret keys
but what where what we've done so far we
have it not the cam
if you put the cam back into the picture
uh the proof breaks down
because the proof uses the fact that r
from s is pseudorandom but now in the
cam s also shows that so now this
statement is no longer true if you're
given a translation
so to fix this uh well turns out what's
true is that if there's an extra ri here
then this statement should not be
and you can basically make sure that
this appears in the proof by modifying
the scheme
and masking the chem key with extra
other reason
and then once you do this to satisfy
correctness you need to add a couple
more uh
more terms to your subject
with those of you familiar with the
prior works essentially you're doing
something like it
to make sure
that uh you're basically doing ipfe
where you encrypt this and giving our
secret keys for r so that all you learn
is
i i you the inner product from small
groups yeah yeah yeah
but i don't know how to prove it as an
interpreter function i could share it
because it's not invasive but you know
if you run the reduction that's
resolution
so uh right so in particular this is
essentially our final scheme
so it's still quite simple so assuming
the evasive out of the assumption for
self-exponential analysis modulus ratio
and out of itself this gives you optimal
broadcast encryption
and moreover if you take uh and this is
for a that's no norm
and if you make a high norm and replace
i with the gadget matrix
then uh we can we get a
cpa b for circuit with short ciphertext
but we don't make an additional function
the assumption is basically this
uh we say is that you know
so when when a is done this is i we
don't have a proof of algebra e let's
say that this is pseudo-random even when
a is high norm and non-tree matrix
so this extra assumption that we need
the thing about this assumption is
qualitatively different from our evasive
lw it doesn't talk about gaussian
trapdoors and also doesn't talk about
functions f okay this for all
x so right so let's sort of uh and this
is the final cpu review so it's still
very simple uh so to conclude all right
so i talked about broadcast encryption
cpa and based
and i think there are a lot of very nice
open problems
uh if you're a quick analyst you can try
to break evasive lwe
if you are into a lattice problems you
can try to do reductions okay uh if
you're into advanced crypto from lwe
uh you can either strive to uh find new
applications for this evasive other
assumption
so uh in fact uh rosa will be talking
about how to use assumption to build our
business encryption we also have
independent uh work with a similar
result and also i think another nice
open problem is to uh get cpav for
circuits from just erased
in particular uh can you get rid of this
explosion
which uh i guess v note was already
suggesting an approach uh i think this
should be quite
good times
[Music]
uber assumption similarly to the ones
that have been made in the context of
you know group based assumptions is
there any hope to formulate the claim
yeah
yeah the closest i know which is not
false is uh
it's uh instantly based on research
let's see it meant something that is
even more general that would imply but
the evasive nwe is saying so what other
applications would it simplify other
things uh so the so with inpatient would
be the only hope you can use it to use
it for is to build uh
are debates
and uh right surprises with the
temperatures
and also ade like objects
um
in general in a non-invasive setting uh
the sunshine is broken and usually the
scheme may be growth reduction
so if you are it's very important that
when you multiply by p the joint
distribution is still written
so
you know if there's any if there's any
uh structure whatsoever that's
detectable for instance when you're
by uniform there's usually an attack on
the
so as far as i know so for instance i i
tried to build some other objects
and i couldn't prove it under the
electrical wbd because
uh s times p is not pseudo value and for
that scheme uh i actually have if you
think a bit more you can check from it
maybe
the assumption is that
you said that the assumption is nothing
but for every distribution field right
for uh for specifications yeah so if you
so you have a scheme uh
and then the p has a buffer distribution
okay so i'm just saying maybe an uber
assumption would say that for every p
that satisfies a certain simple
condition
the assumption here says for every
distribution b
if a is true then so there is no counter
you're saying there is no controlled
counter example for this actually
is that's right the way i interpret this
uh the way i interpret this is uh
you know i think of this if you think
about the
uh generic uh pairing groups i think of
this as quantities in g1 and i think
this is in g2
and this assumption basically states
that the only attacker are the ones that
take things in g1 and g2 and multiply
them together to get objective
so in general model we can prove that
these are only at x but here
we don't even know in fact these are not
the only attacks in our real world
but if you pair everything together and
the joint distribution is already
which is roughly what the precondition
says then in those cases that seems to
me
so
in particular this is an example of uh
something that happens when you're
multiplying together you have
correlation
when correlation group usually the post
conditions
and uh in the sense of the longer true
of exclusive
is there a plausible generic model even
like a very toy generic model in which
something like this holds
uh yeah that's a great question
like
like a real toy model like like it might
be interesting even if like this bears
almost no relationship whatsoever with
the actual assumption right just to show
a model that sort of represents this
behavior yeah i think that's a good
question we don't want good models for
lpm we do i think lpn i think uh lul and
elena and friends have some sort of a
model that seems to capture healthy
enterprise
in lpn type attacks i think the
basically all asset structures freaking
out the form at twice the fine let's try
the sources
that say the intricate resources
uh the only the only way you can break
algebra these resources this is what
happens
and that is the world but here uh in
fact
the preconditions say that cis is hard
with respect to p
so in fact these three distributions
this is okay that's two systems
and this two exists it's hard
so
the precondition roughly says that so
you have the variable saying if sis is
heart then out of relief
um
yeah provide the execution
so you can have cases where if s is no
longer then you can have the case that
system is hard for p but the fourth
question is
so it says uh if p on our matrix that's
this host and then s times law normally
due to the random s
like s is
all right great let's talk